>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Dan Turello: Good afternoon,
welcome to our program.
I'm Dan Turello on staff
for the Kluge Center.
Before we start, I
want to remind you
to please turn off
any cellphones
or other devices
that might interfere.
And I also want to remind you
that we are recording
today's lecture for placement
on the library's Youtube
and iTune channels.
A few words about Kloge
Center before we begin.
It was founded in 2000 thanks to
a donation from John W. Kluge.
The goal of facilitating
scholarly access
to the library's remarkable
collection of knowledge
and engaging thinkers and
scholars in conversation
with lawmakers and
other public figures.
We do this by inviting
scholars into residents,
including predoctoral
and postdoctoral fellows
and senior chairs.
We also administer the
Kluge Prize which is awarded
by the Librarian of
Congress for achievement
in the study of humanity.
Today, it's wonderful to have
Samira Mehta back with us.
Samira recently completed
her time
as a David Larson fellow
at the Kluge Center.
And the Larson Fellowships,
specifically, is made possible
by an endowment from
the International Center
for Integration of
Health and Spirituality.
It's named after David
Larson, an epidemiologist,
I can never say that correctly,
and psychiatrist who focused
on understudied factors that
might help in preventing,
coping, and recovering
from illness.
The fellowship here at the
Kluge Center is designed
to continue Dr. Larson's legacy
of promoting meaningful
scholarly study of two important
and increasingly interrelated
fields, spirituality,
and physical, mental
and social health.
So a few words about Samira
before we invite her up.
She is assistant professor
of religious studies
at Albright College.
She holds a PhD in Religious
Studies from Emory University
and a Masters of
Divinity from Harvard.
Some of the courses she's taught
in the last few years include
early American religious life
to 1865, modern American
religious life from 1865
to the present, Islam and--
Islam ideals and realities,
and finally gender and
sexuality in American religion.
And her book "Beyond
Chrismukkah", a cultural history
of the Christian-Jewish
blended family from 1965
to 2010 is forthcoming,
and I hear it's forthcoming
this spring.
So be on the lookout for
it from the University
of North Carolina Press.
Most recently, she has
been studying the history
of contraception and religion
in America for a new book.
And the title of her talk today
is Morality, Contraception,
and Religion in Post
War America.
So please join me
in welcoming Samira.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Samira K. Mehta:
Welcome and thank you for coming
to my talk today on
contraception, morality,
and religion in post
war America.
I would like to thank
the friends from outside
of the Library of
Congress who are today.
I appreciate your support.
Thank you to John Haskell for
welcoming me back for this talk.
I would also like to
thank my fellow fellows
at the Kluge Center, those
who joined us today and those
who were here with me.
Some of those people overlap
and some of them don't.
In terms of my research, I
can't speak highly enough
of the reference assistance
that I was given, in particular
by Cheryl Adams and
Mary Champagne
in the Main Reading Room, by
Ryan Reft and Edith Sandler
in the Manuscript Division,
and by Martha Kennedy
in Prints and Photographs.
The women's history lunch group
here at the library listened
to an early version of this
talk and helped me select what
of my research might
interest you the most today.
And of course, none of these
experiences would have been
possible without the support of
the staff at the Kluge Center,
Dan and Emily Coccia,
Mary Lou Reker,
my interns Christine
Lee [assumed spelling]
and Emily Kendal Fio
[assumed spelling].
And most specially, I would
like to thank Travis Hensley
for making everything
run more smoothly
and for being an amazing
sounding board and resource
as I navigated the Library of
Congress and the Kluge Center.
Thank you.
Contraception and religion
have been much in the news
over the past several years.
For instance, the 2000--
in 2014, the-- there we go.
The-- It works differently
than the one in my classroom.
In the case of Burwell
versus Hobby Lobby Stores,
Incorporated, the Supreme
Court of the United States,
right through those windows,
ruled that the Religious
Freedom Restoration Act
of 1993 can apply
to corporations.
The Religious Freedom
Restoration Act was proposed
by New York democrat Chuck
Schumer and is intended
to ensure that interests in
religious freedom are protected.
So originally, this act was
intended to apply to people.
That is to say, an organization
could not deny an individual his
or her religious rights.
So think for instance of this
act giving a Muslim student the
right to pray during the school
day or protecting a Wiccan
from being fired because
she practices witchcraft.
The Religious Freedom
Restoration Act stipulated
that it protected the
religious freedoms of persons,
but the Hobby Lobby
cases extended that logic
to corporations through the
concept of corporate personhood.
That is to say that
the court has decided
that because Hobby Lobby is a
closely held corporation ran
by an individual or family
who sincerely held religious
beliefs, oppose certain forms
of contraception, that company
is functionally a person
and may exercise its religious
freedom to exclude such forms
of contraception from its health
insurance policies and coverage.
It may not fire a woman who
uses said contraception or a man
who is sleeping with a
woman who uses such forms
of contraception, but it need
not provide access to it.
The court case was
fought and won
in terms of religious freedom.
Individuals and activists who
objected to the case either did
so because they didn't like
religious freedom being extended
to corporation or because they
didn't really think religious
freedom was the key
issue, rather they saw it
as a red herring and saw
the case as, in the end,
about a conservative attempt
to structure American families
and/or control the sexuality
and reproductive lives
of American women.
So Burwell versus Hobby
Lobby is just one example
of a contemporary moment
when religious freedom
arguments have been used
to restrict women's
access to contraception.
And in each case, there are
people who either see or wanted
to see the religious rights
of the employer triumph
or the religious rights
of the employee triumph.
So, you know, that's kind
of the question there.
Whose religious rights
end up mattering?
And in each case, objections
come both from people
who have opinions about how
that should play out and come
from people who are
concerned that this is really
about conservative
controls of sexuality.
And well, this is basically
a talk about heterosexuality
and contraception,
similar logics play out,
and for instance, court cases
about wedding cakes in the--
in exactly this moment.
So, I'm not actually here
to talk about Hobby Lobby.
I did that in order to give
you a contemporary hook,
a context through which you can
understand some of the history
that I'm going to
talk about today.
If you're interested in
Hobby Lobby, see me after.
I can recommend excellent
scholarship.
But the tensions of religious
freedom and the structure
of American family and the
role of religion in sexuality
in public discourse is not
a unique set of tensions.
It's not something
that came to exist
in the contemporary moment.
Most of my research here
at the Kluge Center looked
at another moment in
the religious history
of reproductive rights,
when religious freedom
and religious responses
to the American family
were actually used
to expand women's
access to contraception.
In part because of cases like
Hobby Lobby and for a myriad
of other reasons well beyond
the scope of today's talk,
really well beyond the scope
of anything you could talk
about in an afternoon.
Most people tend to think
of religion and sexuality
as existing in opposition
to each other.
At best, we think of
the clergy's response
to women's health
as one represented
in this political cartoon.
And as this is being
recorded for use online
and as the slides will not be
part of the online presentation,
please forgive me as I give a
brief summary for the people
who are listening to this later.
The PowerPoint is showing a
political cartoon of a man
and woman leaving a church
at the end of service.
They're at the door and
they're commenting on the sermon
to a clergyman in his vestments.
It's a very high
church kind of look.
And the caption reads
nice waffling on the pill.
The implication suggests what
I think we popularly understand
to be more or less the most
pro-contraception position
of the clergy, waffling.
No clear endorsement that
one might have sex simply
for pleasure or that
contraception might be a moral
or social good.
Rather, an impression that
clergies see marital sex
as generally good an
acceptance of the fact
that the 2.5 child
family is the norm.
Something of a don't ask,
don't tell policy, right?
Like, we're not asking how it is
that this is normal family size.
And that's how people
often think
of religious interactions
with sexuality.
And this common misconception
misses an important piece
of American religious history.
In the 1950s, in the not quite
immediately post war period,
Protestant and Jewish clergy
were central to the battle
to get women access
to birth control.
Today, I'm going to tell you a--
that story in a way that
will demonstrate some
of the shifting relationship
between how American clergy
have connected contraception
and religious freedom,
demonstrating that for middle
of the century Protestant
and Jewish reproduction--
Protestants and Jews
reproduction
and the family provided a
key sight of moral agency,
and one that they were
determined to protect.
And just to give you a bit of a
heads-up about how this is going
to work, the story
I'm going to tell is
about a two-month campaign
waged largely by the Protestant
and Jewish clergy of the
New York metropolitan area,
along with a number of
medical organizations,
and waged against
the commissioner
of the New York municipal
hospitals.
Throughout the talk, I will be
moving between that narrative
and relevant pieces
of background in order
to illuminate what's
going on in that moment.
So we'll be going between 1958
when the story is happening
and varying backstory
conversations that's informing
the action.
And if you'll excuse me, I
am going to take the staple
out of this because I keep
hitting the microphone every
time I turn a page.
There we go.
That is better.
So, I hope that that moving
around in time will help--
will still give you
a clear story
and that the pieces
will all knit together.
But to begin, in 1958, at
the Kings County Hospital
in New York City, and for those
listening online, I have a slide
that has the picture
of the gentlemen
about whom I'm about
to be speaking.
One picture is very good and the
other is a terrible reproduction
from a newspaper, but it was
the best that I could do.
At the Kings County
Hospital in New York City,
a Jewish doctor planned
to fit a Protestant woman
with a diaphragm, or as
all of the records put it,
a contraceptive device.
The young woman was diabetic.
She had just had her first child
and the combination of diabetes
and pregnancy had proved
extremely dangerous.
Doctors feared that another
pregnancy could kill her.
She was young, however,
and scientists were
making massive advances
in diabetes research
and treatment.
She, her husband,
and her doctors hoped
that medicine would
advance enough to allow her
to safely sustain a pregnancy
while she was still young enough
to bear children.
As a result, they
wanted to provide her
with contraception
rather than sterilization.
Her doctor, Louis Hellman,
was the director of obstetrics
and gynecology at
Kings County Hospital.
And they scheduled
her fitting at 10:00
in the morning on
July 16th, 1958.
At 9:30 that morning,
Dr. Hellman went
to the hospital supervisor, Dr.
Harvey Gollance to inform him
that he would be fitting his
patient with a diaphragm.
Dr. Gollance informed
Dr. Hellman
that the New York City Hospital
commissioner, Dr. Morris Jacobs,
had forbidden him to proceed.
Dr. Hellman requested that Dr.
Jacobs put the order in writing.
Dr. Gollance said he would
need to telephone Dr. Jacobs.
Dr. Hellman returned to
his own office to wait.
At 10:15, so 15 minutes after
the appointment was scheduled,
Dr. Gollance called and
said that the order stood
but that Dr. Jacobs would
not put it in writing.
So Dr. Hellman was somewhat
surprised by this news.
While it had long been an
unwritten rule that doctors
in municipal hospitals
were forbidden
from prescribing birth control,
over the course of the spring
of 1958, the policy
appeared to be relaxing,
like the hospitals seemed
to be backpedaling a bit.
Just a few months earlier,
the New York Academy
of Physicians has
questioned Jacobs
as to the city's
policy on contraception.
On April 11th, 1985, Jacobs had
written to them that the care
and treatment of patients
are the responsibility
of the medical board.
"There shall be no
interference in proper
and accepted therapeutic
practices, nor intervention
in ethical relationships
between patient
and physician," Jacobs
had written.
Most physicians interpreted
Jacob's statement to mean
that birth control decisions
were up to individual hospitals
or the individual ethics boards
of hospitals and their doctors.
Hellman himself had told the New
York Herald Tribune that prior
to April 11th, he would not have
been able to provide a woman
with a medically necessary
contraceptive device,
but he believed that the April
11th decisions had changed that.
Granted, the Herald
Tribune noted,
several questions
remain unsettled.
For instance, while Jacobs
appeared to relax the rules,
hospital pharmacies did not
stock contraceptive devices.
Did his statement mean that
they would start doing so?
Or would patients be able
to receive a prescription
that they would then have to
take to a private pharmacy?
As it turned out, the latter.
After the April 11th
announcement,
Dr. Hellman ordered
contraceptive devices
for the Kings County Hospital,
and the order was never filled.
But on May 4th, when
he gave this interview
to the Herald Tribune,
Hellman told the paper
that he was very satisfied
with Jacobs's new stance.
So when faced with
this diabetic patient,
Dr. Hellman followed all
of the outlined protocols.
He went to the Kings County
Hospital executive committee
for permission to provide his
patient with contraception.
On July 1st, they granted
him permission to proceed.
This was unusual but it
was not unprecedented.
Kings County Hospital had,
at three different points,
ruled that the hospital could
provide therapeutic birth
control when it was
deemed medically necessary.
That is to say, a couple could
not have birth control simply
because they wanted to
space out their children.
They couldn't decide they did
not want to have children.
They could not decide
that eight was enough.
They could, however, have
birth control for reasons
like the one outlined above.
There was a medical reason to
delay or space out childbearing,
but the couple desired to
preserve the possibility
of having children in the future
should the mother's health
or should the medical
interventions available
to the mother change.
So the reversal of this
decision 15 minutes before--
after he was supposed to
see his patient surprised
and dismayed Dr. Hellman.
He did, however, also feel
that it tied his hands.
He did not fit his patient
for the contraceptive device,
but he did go to the newspapers.
The next morning, The New York
Times reported on the situation.
And I would just like to
say The New York Times
and the New York Herald Tribune
and the New York Post were all
over this like white on rice.
So there's a fantastic record.
Since the ban was not official,
there was no official
explanation
for why contraception
was functionally banned.
In his book "Sacred Work",
public theologian Tom
Davis hypothesized
that the answer was
the Catholic Church.
And again, for those
listening online,
what I have here is a
slide with a prelate,
and it says underneath, the pill
is a no-no, and he's pointing
like Uncle Sam, as in, you know,
we want you for the US Army.
So the New York City electorate
was 80-- was 48% catholic.
And the Catholic Church
firmly opposed contraception.
Catholics might not appreciate
their tax dollars going
to support contraception
and public facilities.
Davis argued essentially
that the New York City
elected officials were afraid
that if they appeared to
support birth control,
the church would condemn them,
and they would be
voted out of office.
For a modern example,
think for instance
of John Kerry being denied
communion by Cardinal Burke
for his stance on abortion.
On some level, I find
Davis's argument compelling,
but I'm not fully convinced, at
least not by the electoral math.
Forty-eight percent is a
lot, but it's not a majority.
And perhaps more importantly,
within only a few years
of the birth control pill
being approved by the FDA,
Debra Hendler [assumed
spelling],
historian /Debra
Hendler's research tells us
that Catholic women
would use contraception
at essentially the same rate as
their Protestant counterparts.
It seems to me that New
York City politicians,
and many of whom were
Catholic, probably realized
that many Catholic
voters would break
with the church on
contraception.
And so, I'm flagging this mostly
as a place where I'm planning
to do some more research
around why birth control
was carefully restricted
in New York municipal settings.
Taking a look at the money
and where it's coming from,
what the positions of individual
political figures may have been.
But the Catholic Church aside,
there are some other
reasons why birth control was
so hard to come by.
For about 75 years, birth
control and information
about birth control had
been restricted largely
on the grounds that
it was indecent.
In 1873, Congress had
passed something called the
Comstock Act.
Anti-pornography laws for
the suppression of trade in,
and circulation of,
obscene literature
and articles of immoral use.
Essentially, for our purposes,
the Comstock laws made
it illegal to talk about,
write publicly about,
or ship birth control.
This picture of Margaret
Sanger in 1929 shares some
of the ramifications of, if not,
the Comstock laws themselves
which were federal, the
attitudes that they represented.
Margaret Sanger was
a trained nurse
and an early birth
control activist.
She was both the founder of the
American Birth Control League,
now Planned Parenthood, and
one of the early proponents
of the birth control pill.
She did a lot of the
fundraising that went
into funding the research that
would bring about the pill.
In 1916, she had opened the
country's first birth control
clinic in Brownville, Brooklyn.
It remained open
for about a month.
Throughout her career, she was
arrested for her activities.
And throughout the 1920's,
Margaret Sanger was
famously banned in Boston.
She was prevented by Mayor
James Curley from speaking
in 1923, 1924, and 1925.
This photo, which is from 1929,
is a moment when she appeared
on stage wearing a gag.
She was not able to
speak, and the eminent
and male historian Arthur
Schlesinger read her prepared
remarks for her while she sat
there or stood there gagged.
It was a brilliant
publicity stunt.
And so, what you have here is
you have a fairly significant
history of birth control being
something that is legally,
often forbidden,
highly restricted, very,
very problematic, and
because of reasons of decency,
information is extremely
limited as well.
So the need to avoid over
mention of contraception led
to some coy ads and interesting
forms of birth control.
During the same decade that
Sanger was banned in Boston,
these ads for Lysol appeared in
a number of women's magazines.
For those of you
watching online,
the slide that I'm showing
depicts three different
advertisements for Lysol.
The first shows an older sister
advising her younger sister
in what is clearly an
intimate conversation.
The caption reads, lucky
bride to have an older sister.
The second image depicts
a woman wiping away a tear
with a handkerchief, worlds--
words swirl around her
head saying inhibitions,
ignorance, doubt, misgivings.
The caption reads, do
inhibitions, parenthesis doubts,
threaten married love?
One small intimate physical
neglect can rob a wife
of her husband's love.
The last image shows a portrait
of a lovely and well made
up woman and says, she was the
perfect wife with just one flaw.
She was guilty of
the one neglect
that mars many marriages.
Lysol helps avoid this.
So these ads explicitly in
small text refer to Lysol
as a feminine hygiene product.
But as historian Adrian Tone--
Andrea Tone makes clear,
everyone understood that these
ads were really promoting
douching with Lysol as a
method of contraception.
As a method, it was ineffective
and had potential
side effects ranging
from inflammation to death.
But condoms and diaphragms
were both very expensive
and very hard to come by.
So these examples should give
you a sense of the climate
in the first quarter of the 20th
century in the United States
when it came to conversations
about methods of
and access to birth control.
It was limited.
There were laws in place
that made the information
almost impossible to come by,
and the devices were
even harder to access.
As a result, there was something
of a coded language for talking
about birth control, but
no real control over it,
which is how Lysol could
advertise itself by implication
as a contraceptive, even though
using it could result in death.
So the images that we just
saw all came from the 1920s.
The federal courts repeal
the Comstock laws in 1936.
Birth control is no
longer considered obscene,
and it can be transferred
across state lines.
But there's no broadly held
social sense that women
or men had the right
to contraception
or to what we might call,
and what they were
strategically starting to call,
family planning services,
as the example
from New York City makes clear.
And there's a gap, right, of
22 years between the repeal
of the Comstock laws
and the 1958 case.
But not very much had
changed on the access
to contraception front.
If access had not changed,
however, the religious reactions
to contraception really had.
The religious community had
been more or less in support
of the Comstock Acts
when they had passed
in the late 19th century.
But in the middle
of the 20th century,
it's an entirely
different picture.
Since the early decades of
the 20th century, main line
and liberal Protestant
dominations issued statements
on ideal Christian family life.
And unfortunately, the rest
of my talk doesn't really
lend itself to photos.
And so this is Kings
County Hospital,
the setting for everything.
And it's not actually even
a particularly historically
accurate picture of Kings
Hospital and that I took it.
And I wasn't alive then.
So--
Sorry, I lost my place.
Yes. So since the early decades
of the 20th century, main line
and liberal protestant
denominations issued statements
on ideal Christian family life.
These statements held that for
the contemporary protestant
with the medical means to do
so, family planning was vital
because it allowed
for a more thoughtful
and deliberate creation
of Christian families.
In 1931, the Committee
on Marriage and Home
of the United States
Federal Council
of Churches declared the
careful and restrained use
of contraceptives by married
couple was valid and moral
if used to safeguard the
health of mother and child.
And protect the livelihood
and stability of the family.
No direct action came
from this statement,
but it prompted much public
debate and represented a shift
from commonly held Protestant
condemnation of contraception.
That same year,
the Congregational Christian
General Council announced its
support of voluntary
childbearing
to safeguard the wellbeing
of family and society.
In 1954, the Augustana
Evangelical Lutheran Churches
in America adopted a statement
advocating for the spacing
of children so as to
ensure their proper care
and the health of the mother.
While the Anglican Communion's
Lambeth Conference had condemned
birth control in 1908
and 1920, by 1958,
it stated that contraception
was a primary obligation
of Christian marriage,
that children may be born
within the supporting
framework of parental love
and family concern with
the right to an opportunity
for a full and spiritually
wholesome life.
Taking into account factors
such as the cost of education
and the increased
social assumption
that you would send your
children to college,
the Lambeth Conference
which, remember,
had condemned birth control
twice within the past 50 years,
actually chastised
parents who carelessly
and improvidently bring
children into the world trusting
in an unknown future
or a generous society
to care for them.
So these Protestant
denominations connected the
freedom to make one's own
decision about reproduction
with a responsibility to create
and maintain a healthy family.
And they were very interested
in getting people the freedom
to decide how to create
their own families.
These were by and
large policy statements
from the varying denominations.
They weren't carefully
fleshed out theologies.
They were intended
for the guidance
of their own clergy
rather than an attempt
that pan-Protestant
approach to birth control.
However, they had clear
moral implications
and they provided a
framework as it became evident
in the New York City
clergy's response
to the birth control ban.
More or less simultaneous
with the 1958 example,
Protestants were beginning
to talk about something
that they called
responsible parenthood.
Though the first major book
on responsible parenthood was
still two years away, 1960,
and the National Council
of Churches were three--
was three years away from
passing a statement in support
of responsible parenthood,
1961, and parenthetically,
it did that with 83 votes in
favor of responsible parenthood,
zero votes against,
and four abstentions.
The idea of-- is already
in 1958 really circulating
in Protestants or cults.
So what is responsible
parenthood?
Responsible parenthood is
an attempt to synthesize
and create an appropriate
relationship
between religion and science.
The religiously mandated
responsibility to be stewards
of the good-- of the Earth-- to
be good stewards of the Earth,
the responsibilities that
Christian parents had
for their children,
and the autonomy
of the Protestant couple in
making their own decisions
about childrearing
were connected
to a theologically
unified approach
to the emerging medical
technologies of contraception.
Responsible parenthood
served as a counterweight
to conservative Protestant
voices, and it was a challenge
to protestant conversations
with the Catholic Church.
In responsible parenthood,
contraception became both
marital and moral, right?
So nobody is talking about
contraception outside
of marriage, nobody in
this conversation anyway.
But in that context, it is
seen as shoring up rather
than eroding traditional
Christian values.
Now, the moral reasons
for limiting the size
of one's family, according to
this theology, were multifold
but there were three
primary reasons.
First, concern for the planet.
This is huge.
In 1954, none other than
Harry Emerson Fosdick,
one of the most prominent
Protestant ministers
of the first half of the 20th
century, much more liberal
than Billy Graham but sort
of similarly important
to Billy Graham, framed
overpopulation as one
of the world's basic problems
which could be relieved
by knowledge of and
access to contraception,
a desire for healthy and
appropriate family life.
In that same 1954 speech
which Fosdick delivered
at a planned parenthood awards
dinner, he said that the liberty
to use contraceptive control
to build thoughtfully planned,
wise planned homes was
essential to proper family life.
And three, and I think
this is very interesting,
the sense that married
couples had vocational work
to do in the world.
And while it was hoped
that parenthood was one
of their vocations, Christian
clergy should not assume
that it was the couple's
sole vocation.
By limiting the number
of children in a family,
a couple would be better able
to fill all of their multi--
bleh, bleh, bleh-- all of them
many vocations and interact
with childrearing as
a vocational work,
giving it the care and
attention that did not--
they felt scale very well.
You can do things with
one, two, three children
that you cannot do with 14.
Perhaps most importantly, all
three of these points call
for individual moral
agency in making decisions.
No agency, no government agency,
no hospital, no denomination,
and no minister, was to
impose reproductive decisions
on a couple.
They were to make them together
after prayerful contemplation.
Reproduction in the schema
became an extremely important
venue for Protestant
moral agency.
All of these ideas and the
social attitudes behind them,
about which we can talk
more during questions,
informed the public campaign
that the New York
metropolitan areas, Protestant
and Jewish clergy were about
to wage against Morris Jacobs.
And I realized I've been
talking about Protestants.
I will be getting to the
Jews in just a moment.
As I said at the beginning of
the talk, it was July 16th,
1958 when Jacob-- Dr. Jacobs
forbade Dr. Louis Hellman
to fit the young
diabetic wife and mother
with a contraceptive device.
Less than a week later, the New
York Herald Tribune reported
that Arthur A. Allen, a man with
three first names, the chairman
of the Department of
Christian Social Relations
for the Protestant Council
of the City of New York,
had telegraphed Jacobs
requesting an immediate meeting.
Jacobs declined to meet
with the Protestant council.
But note the dates here.
The patient was denied
her contraceptive fitting
on the 16th.
The story broke in the New York
Times on the 17th, the next day.
By the time the paper
was-- for 23rd was typeset,
the Protestant council
had already reached
out to Jacobs and been rebuffed.
I don't know how many
of you have actively
engaged religious lives,
but most decisions, especially
most decisions made amongst
Protestants and Jews,
liberal Jews,
the group that we are talking
about, are made democratically.
It takes time.
The fact that they were able
to act this quickly is really
indicative of a broadly based--
broad-based consensus.
They felt that they had a
mandate to speak with Jacobs.
And they ultimately did meet
with him in early August.
And they made their
disapproval of the ban known.
So that's late July.
On August 12th, The New
York Times ran a headline
that announced, Harlem
Pastors Criticized Jacobs.
Commissioner's Stand on
Birth Control is also decried
by Rabbis.
Specifically, the group ministry
of the East Harlem Protestant
Parish had issued a statement
that said, the lives
of many children
in our communities
are impoverished
or permanently scarred
because they are deprived
of the basic emotional and
material stability necessary
for their healthy development.
Consequently, we believe
it is immoral in the face
of such facts to withhold
adequate instruction
in contraceptive techniques
from those individuals
in our communities who in
clear conscience desire
to control the size
of their families.
They went on to point
out that most
of their community could not
afford private hospitals.
They could only go
to city hospitals.
Therefore, if the city hospitals
did not offer contraception,
most residents of East
Harlem could not access it.
The rabbis in the
headline were the Orthodox
Rabbinical Alliance.
I know, I just said liberal
Jews, the Orthodox Jews were
in fact also part
of this process.
The Orthodox Rabbinical
Alliance, meanwhile,
explained that Orthodox Judaism
permitted contraception only
on certain conditions.
It had to be practiced by the
woman and not the man which is
to say that they did not
favor condoms as a mode
of contraception for reasons
rooted in the Book of Leviticus.
They also only wanted
contraception practiced
for health reasons.
So this was a health of the
mother issue or the health
of the children to whom
she was giving birth.
This was not a family limitation
for reasons having to do
with how you imagined
your family.
And it could only occur after
consultation with both medical
and religious authorities.
Even with all of
those restrictions,
the Orthodox Rabbinical Alliance
objected to Jacob's policy
as they felt that it set
the hospital's policy
to the attendance
of one specific faith,
the Catholic faith.
They didn't say that but
everyone else was saying
that it was the Catholic faith.
Such an action, they wrote,
jeopardizes the hallowed
American tradition
that government mental
agencies must be divorced
from the influence of any
particular religious group
and that these agencies
must never seek to impose
on the people they serve
any kind of sectarian view.
So in other words, even
though this is a group
with a fairly strict sense of
how you can use contraception,
they want the government
to stay out of it.
They want the medical technology
available and they want women,
potentially married
couples, to make the decision
after a conversation with
a doctor and a rabbi.
And if one is going to
give this a feminist read,
it is certainly true then that
a woman is making a decision
in a conversation with a
bare minimum of three men,
her husband, her
doctor and her rabbi.
But it is still arguing
that it is a decision
that should be made on
that individual ground.
So, you know, important to have
both of those things in mind.
Onward with our timeline.
Three days later,
on August 15th,
the Interdenominational
Ministers Alliance in Brooklyn,
with some 150 members
who pastored some 175,000
of Brooklyn's Protestants,
announced in the same paper
that they were in
complete agreement
with the Protestant council and
sought a meeting with Jacobs.
Among these 175,000
parishioners was
in fact Hellman's diabetic
Protestant patient.
The alliance of-- issued
an official statement.
Our ministers cannot understand
why Dr. Jacobs turned his back
on his own profession and
interfered with the proper
and accepted treatment of one
of our church members whose
very life is dependent
on such treatment.
So essentially, the
Ministers Alliance just said,
why is the doctor trying to
kill one of our parishioners?
They went on to affirm
in a statement
that the Protestant
council had made
in their early August
meeting with Jacobs.
The use of medically approved
contraceptive devices practiced
in Christian conscience
fulfills rather
than violates the will of God.
Jacobs agreed to see the
Interdenominational Ministers
Alliance, after all he had just
seen the Protestant council,
but he also said that he would
not drop the birth control ban.
So we're now in mid August.
On August 23rd, Rabbi
Edward F. Klein
of the Stephen Wise Free
Synagogue called Dr. Jacobs's
ban an infringement on civil
rights, the civil rights
of the patient, the civil
rights of the Protestant
and Jewish communities.
He elaborated.
A physician is entitled by
the nature of his profession
to pursue his work in
accordance with the best legal
and medical procedures.
Protestant and Jewish
patients are entitled
to receive the best medical
treatment even though some
procedures may be contrary to
the teachings of other faiths.
That is to say Catholics
are of course free
to follow the dictates
of Catholic faith.
Protestants and Jews are
not obligated to follow
and should not be functionally
obligated by a municipal system
to follow the dictates
of the Catholic faith.
My possible favorite, on
September 1st, again according
to the New York Harold Tribune,
the Reverend George
Stewart [assumed spelling],
assistant director of the Saint
James Protestant Episcopal
Church at Madison
in 71st preached
that birth control is Christian.
He did this on the-- from
the pulpit on Sunday morning,
on the Upper Eastside.
In his sermon, Reverend
Stewart preached,
and this is a direct
quote, "The sex act is one
of the greatest treasures
of marriage, irrespective
of its purpose of pregnancy.
Therefore parents who in
Christian conscience wish
to plan their family may use
contraceptive methods or devices
in their sex relation and
secure the other great spiritual
benefits without
involving contraception."
He went on, "The use of
contraceptive devices
for effective family
planning is consistent
with a realistic understanding
of the nature and purpose
of sex relations in marriage.
Birth control is Christian."
There are lots of things
that are worth unpacking
in that comment, for instance,
the slippage between talking
about a couple, a married
couple and parents.
A married couple are
assumed to be synonymous
with the word parents.
The idea here is not
whether to have children,
it's how many and when.
That is part of the
operating assumption here.
And also notice that the
assumption here is again
marital sexuality.
But that said, this is an
extremely sex positive message.
This is not a message that says,
we really wish you
could help yourselves,
but we did say it's better
to marry than to burn.
And I suppose since we can
prevent women from dying
of having 15 children,
we might as well.
Right? That's not
the message here.
The message here
is sex is sacred.
Sex in a marriage is
good and it is important
for things other
than having children.
Now, we know you
will have children.
We know you would never
consider not having children,
but we understand that you
might sometimes want to have sex
for good, moral,
spiritual reasons.
Notice, he's also not
saying and it's really fun.
He is saying there are all
of these religious reasons
and parenthood is one of them
but it's not the only one.
Just immediately prior to
the September 17th meeting
of the Board of Hospitals, which
is where the decision was going
to be finally debated
and towards
which Morris Jacobs had
been kicking the can more
or less all summer, 11
Unitarian ministers wrote
to the hospital board asking
them to overrule Jacobs because,
as the Reverend James M.
Hutchinson of Flushing,
Queens put it, "The denial
of contraception was unwise
and a denial of the rights
of full medical treatment."
According to the Unitarians,
Jacobs was making a moral
decision that rightly belonged
to the individual patient.
And I'm just going to
parenthetically add
for any colleagues of
mine in the UU Scholars
and Friends group who are
listening to this, it's 1958,
that's why I said Unitarians
and Unitarian Universalists.
Joining the general outcry
where the 17-member
medical advisory committee
of the planned parenthood
of Manhattan and the Bronx,
who wrote to Jacobs and
to the board of hospitals,
sighting the American Medical
Association's ethical guidelines
that physicians not base
medical care on the--
an exclusive dogma
or sectarian system,
a comment that clearly
indicated their sense
that the Catholic Church,
a single religious entity,
was holding sway over the
New York City medical system.
And similarly, the equally
secular New York Women's Club
of New York wrote
to Jacobs urging him
to make contraception available.
In the voices of the clergy,
you hear any number of concerns
that religious actors,
and in this case,
largely religious leaders and
male religious leaders brought
to the debate about
contraception.
First, among the traditions
that allow contraception,
you hear a range of
opinions about when
and why it might be
used, ranging from health
of the mother to-- sort of at
will as long as children are
in the grand scheme things,
part of the pan and the picture.
The pro-contraception side
does not necessarily agree
with itself about how
contraception is to be used,
which is part of why they
were all inclined to view this
as a religious freedom issue.
They don't want to have to live
with each other's
determination either.
They want this to be a decision
that a couple is making--
in conversation with them, the
clergy, and in conversation
with who they understand
to be the other pertinent
expert, the doctor.
And they are self-understanding,
and many,
many doctors are agreeing
with them that the experts
in question, there should be
a clergyperson, clergyman,
and there should be a doctor.
This is not a decision for a
couple to make on their own.
This is considered to be
really very, very weighty,
and something for authorities.
If a hospital provides
contraceptive services,
the clergy can then help them--
their parishioners decide how
to access it, their
congregants decide.
Clergy and wealthy
congregations,
like the Upper Westside
congregation, have the space
to talk about sex as enjoyable.
Clergy in less affluent
conversations talk
about the harm that many
mouths can do to families,
the reality that children
cost money and the reality
that the more hours you work,
the less emotional time you
might have to give them.
Clergy raised questions
of maternal health.
In many of these conversations,
the family in changing ideals
of what makes a family
shape the comments.
There is an ability to
limit the size of the family
and it becomes a space
for moral agency.
All of a sudden, this is venue
in which people can take action
and in which the clergy really
feel that people should.
And while only the religious
minority, the Jewish voices,
emphasized the religious freedom
element in their comments
to the press, religious
freedom is underlying all
of the other comments.
For a hospital to align its
policies with Catholic views is
to deny Protestants as much
as Jews the religious freedom
to participate in
this new and key venue
of Christian moral
agency, the moral choice,
the Christian choices about
how to navigate family life
and vocation, about how to
parent, about how to be spouses.
Contraception from the
Protestant standpoint had opened
up all of these venues as
places for moral agency.
And Protestant moral
agency always at its base is
to rest with the individual.
So let me finish the
story very briefly.
On September 17th, 1958, after
a fairly unremitting campaign
by the clergy of the New
York metropolitan area,
the Protestant and
Jewish clergy,
the Board of Hospitals
reversed its position
and allowed the therapeutic
prescription of contraception.
Jacobs made it clear that the
contraception would only be
offered for medical reasons,
not for sociological
or emotional reasons.
The hospital policy
also specified
that any Roman Catholic and the
some Orthodox Jewish doctors,
nurses and other hospital staff
who objected would not be forced
to provide contraception.
I always wonder whether
that extends to the person
in the billing department,
who doesn't want
to have to process the claim.
I don't know.
I really do legitimately
wonder how that got navigated.
In part, in addition, before
hospital suggested contraception
to a woman, more than one
doctor would have to agree
that it was medically mandated.
The woman would then be
given an opportunity to speak
with a clergyman of her choice.
And again, I use the term
"clergyman" deliberately.
In addition to the
formal protocol,
newspaper coverage said that
the hospital board had indicated
that a woman might not
be able to gain access
to contraception unless she
had previously been pregnant
and her prior pregnancy
had endangered her life.
And therefore, it
seemed a safe assumption
that subsequent pregnancies
would as well.
They said that the previous
pregnancy rule would not be--
it wouldn't be uniformly
applied.
You could potentially go
in with a clearly medically
diagnosed condition.
But really, it was going
to be extremely difficult
without that prior
life risking situation.
So the compromise did not offer
the full range of contraception
for which the clergy called.
The decision did
not give couples,
at least those using the city
hospitals, the kind of access
to contraception that
responsible parenthood required.
The New York City Municipal
Hospital system ended
up in this case far
more conservative
than the Protestant main line.
And again, the Protestant
main line means not right wing
Christianity but it doesn't
necessarily mean left
wing Christianity.
It can be the middle
of the road.
Than the middle of the
road Protestant position
and almost all of New York
City's forms of Judaism.
And I'm cognizant of time
and so I will stop here,
but I hope we can have
a robust conversation
with what we have left.
[ Inaudible ]
Debbie.
There isn't.
It's a really interesting
question and one that I would
like to look into more
looking into records
at the New York Public Library
and planned parenthoods
records which are at Smith.
My guess based on the newspaper
accounts is that probably not
because in all of
these conversations,
he basically denies that
things are going to change.
He doesn't say, you know, this
is a conversation that we need
to have when the board
meets in September.
He says no, I'm not going to
change the policy, and in fact,
I'm not going to talk to you,
every single minister in town.
But it's an interesting
question.
There also isn't proof
that he didn't, right?
Cameron?
[ Inaudible ]
So the question was twofold.
Was there a Catholic response
and did these conversations
about contraception tie into
conversations about abortion?
So, yes, there was
a Catholic response.
The Catholic Church said in
varying ways, at varying moments
over the two months, look,
we are not controlling
the hospital system
like we are the puppet master.
They didn't use the word "puppet
master" but they were in--
they kept saying like we do
not have the kind of control
that people are suggesting
that we have.
They also said that if the
City of New York chooses
to do something that we consider
immoral, we are absolutely going
to publicly say that the City
of New York has done something
that we consider to be immoral.
So what they are saying is this
is not applying our sectarian
rules to everyone else,
we are not in charge.
We do, however, have the
right to free speech,
exactly like the rest of
you do, and we will use it.
So that was essentially
the position.
They were also very
concerned that no change
in hospital policy result
in Catholics being forced
to operate against their own
conscience and made certain--
or participated in conversations
and said you must make certain
that if you change policy,
that does not happen.
In terms of abortion, you know,
I think almost deliberately, no.
It is also true that Kings
County Hospital was supposed
to report any woman who
came in for treatment
of what was non-hospital
performed abortion.
And they got dramatically
more-- tens--
hundreds more than
they reported.
And so, you get the sense
that the hospital knows exactly
what is going on, is concerned
about what is going on.
And that is part of what's
informing all of the doctors,
because illegal abortion
is really dangerous,
and the doctors were the
people cleaning it up,
but nothing overt
in the conversation.
I'm sorry, I-- we have
had so many conversations,
and I know that your
name is unusual,
but I cannot remember
what it is, yes.
[Inaudible] Thank you,
Jarretta [assumed spelling].
I'm sorry.
[ Inaudible ]
So the questions were two-fold.
First, how much is the strength
of the Protestant response
to the birth control issue, not
actually about birth control
but about anti-Catholicism.
And the second question
was, this is just
about municipal hospitals,
correct,
and so there's a class
issue at work here too.
So, first of all, absolutely.
I have been known
to say jokingly,
and since this is being
recorded for the internet,
I hasten to say I'm
saying this jokingly,
you can get in the middle of
the 20th century Protestants
to oppose almost
anything if you tell them
that Catholics are for it.
And vice versa, right?
You can get them to support
almost anything if you tell them
that Catholics are against it.
And I'm being flip.
But I do think that
there is a lot of concern
about Catholic control.
There's a lot of question
about who is going
to be the dominant
Christian voice
in the American public
conversation,
who's going to call the
shots in that conversation.
This is a moment
of immense power
for the Protestant main line.
But it is, in a lot of ways,
the last moment of immense power
for the Protestant main line.
I don't know to what
extent people know that.
That's-- This is, I mean,
early days of this project,
but that's one of the questions
that is in the back of my head.
And so, yes, absolutely.
And I think that that is-- But I
also think they're very serious
about the moral responsibility
and the individual moral
responsibility to think
about family planning.
One of the things
that Protestants say a lot
during this time period is,
look, Catholics says that
birth control is unnatural,
but the population is exploding.
The reason that population
is exploding is largely
because we have much
better medicine.
And so, we have less
infant mortality,
we have antibiotics,
we have vaccines.
And so, you end up with
all of your children living
to adulthood and it's
causing a problem.
If vaccines and antibiotics are
not unnatural or acceptable,
then birth control
should be as well.
And so that is explicitly
an anti-Catholic theology
in some ways.
Like, that's who they're arguing
with when they're arguing
about what is natural.
But it's also a positive claim.
And absolutely, also,
it is a class issue.
If you are a member of the
Episcopal Church at 71st
in Madison, you are really
close to the mansions
of Central Par, right?
And you can get whatever is
legally available to you.
And in fact, at this point,
contraception is
illegal in Connecticut.
And one of the standard
approaches is to get
on the train into New York.
And I think part of how you
can tell that there is this--
One of the ways that
you can tell
that there is this anti-Catholic
edge to it, is that,
clergy whose congregations do
not need to worry about this,
are very happy to be
part of the conversation.
Nancy.
[ Inaudible ]
So I have not seen the sort
of social history numbers.
The numbers that I have
seen come from organizations
like planned parenthood.
Oh, so the question was,
essentially about the
demographics of this.
What kind of access
is available?
And I'm very much, in
my own orientation,
a cultural historian.
And so, part of what I enjoy
about our friendship is
that you ask me questions
like and keep me honest.
But a lot of the numbers that
I've seen are coming from,
for instance, planned
parenthood.
And I-- And my sense is that
they are there for sure.
But they're also restricted
in what they can do by some
of these same hospital policies.
Over the course of 1958,
leading up to this case,
there had been a series of
exposs in the New York Post
that talk explicitly about
the fact that if you are,
for instance, a settlement house
and you're getting free rent
from the city, you are forbidden
from having a family
planning conversation
with a representative
planned parenthood
in the settlement house, or the
city will, at the very least,
start charging you rent
and possibly evict you.
And they might charge
you back rent, right?
And again, none of it
is a written policy.
These are things that the
reporter whose name I believe
was Joe Con [assumed spelling]
goes and finds out as he moves
around settlement houses and
a number of other places.
So all of those, yes, there
is planned parenthood.
Alan Guttmacher is in-- is
at Mount Sinai at this point.
And so, he-- and he
is a very active voice
in this conversation.
But then you end
up-- there are issues
of distance and transportation.
The private hospitals are
in wealthier parts of town,
you know, getting there, getting
back all of those questions.
And I think there is a large
swath of people who are,
you know, as they're so
often are, there are people
who are too wealthy to get
the real aid being offered,
but don't have the money
or don't have the good
private insurance.
[ Inaudible ]
Right.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, all for coming.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.